in the last few videos we've been
approximating the area under the curve
using rectangles where the height of
each rectangle was defined by the left
boundary
of or the function evaluated at the left
boundary so this would have been
the first rectangle then the second
rectangle would look something like this
and then we'd go all the way to the nth
rectangle would look something
would look something like that and we
saw so this is the first rectangle this
is the second rectangle and we go all
the way to the nth rectangle and so we
saw that the way that you would take the
sum of all of these rectangles in order
to approximate the area is that you
would get
you would get the sum from i equals 1 to
n and so i is essentially a count of
which rectangle we're dealing with and
what we're going to do is multiply the
height times the base so the height of
each rectangle the height of rectangle 1
in this case was the function evaluated
at x naught the height of rectangle 2
was a function evaluated x1 the height
of function the height of the of
rectangle n was a function evaluated x x
sub n minus 1. so the height of
rectangle i is going to be the function
evaluated x sub i
minus 1. if we're dealing with if i is 2
then we're evaluating it at x 1. if i is
2 if i was 2 then this would be the
function evaluated at x1 so it's the
left boundary and then we have to
multiply it times the width and in the
last few videos and in this video we
will assume that all of the rectangles
have equal width and we'll call that
equal with delta x and to find it we
just have to take the total distance
that we're going in the x direction so
it's going to be b
minus a divided by the number of
rectangles we want so it's going to be
times delta x
now you might imagine that this is not
the only way to take the sum using
rectangles or this is not the only way
to take the sum or approximate the area
using some type of geometric shape for
example we could have created rectangles
that where the height is defined by the
rightmost boundary so let's define that
so here's our first rectangle
here's our first rectangle and we're
defining the height by the right
boundary of the rectangle
the right boundary of the rectangle so
this right over here is rectangle one
and its height is f of x one
f of x one and then for this one right
over here
we take the right boundary
the right boundary defines that height
if we go all the way to the this is
rectangle two if we go all the way to
the nth one
we use
the right boundary
we use the right boundary to define the
height of the rectangle so in this case
this is the nth rectangle what how would
we do how would we write this sum
well it would be the sum
the which is well remember we're just
trying to approximate the area under the
curve
from i is equal to 1 to n so i is the
count of each of the rectangles and so
the height of the first rectangle is f
of x1 the height of the nth rectangle is
f of x sub n so this height right over
here
is f of x sub n so the height of the ith
rectangle is going to be f of x sub
i whatever the rectangle number is we
take the x sub that same number and
evaluate the function there that gives
us the height and we multiply that times
delta x so the difference between this
and this here for the eighth rectangle
we use x sub i minus one so the left
boundary here we use the right boundary
f
f of x sub i
but that we don't have to stop there
instead we could use maybe the midpoint
between the two boundaries instead so
for example
over here we could
we could use the midpoint between x
naught and x one
to define the height of the rectangle
so this is right over here this is
f of
f of
x naught plus x one
over two just the midpoint between these
two points to define
the height of the rectangle so it would
look something
like that and the next one we would look
at the midpoint to define the height
midpoint to define the height and we go
all the way to the nth one and we define
the midpoint between its two sides of
the rectangle so the function evaluated
there tells us
how high our rectangle should be
how high our rectangle should be and it
would look something
like that and so what would this sum
look like well once again we would count
each of our rectangles so i equals 1 to
i equals n i is our which rectangle
we're working on so this is the first
one this is the second one this is the
nth one
and the height isn't just going to be f
evaluated x sub i minus 1 or f evaluated
x sub i it'll be the function
evaluated at the midpoint between the
two x sub i minus 1 plus
x sub i
all of that over 2 and then times delta
x the delta x's are the same in every
one of these
every one of these scenarios
now finally let's try to break out of
approximating only with rectangles and
get a little bit more creative why don't
we try to approximate with trapezoids
so let's try to do that so what we could
have here is the left part of the
trapezoid the height is
f of x sub naught
so this is f of x sub naught and then
the right side of the trapezoid
the right side of the trapezoid is f of
x sub 1.
f of x sub 1.
and then what would be the error let me
do that for all of them so that would be
the first trapezoid then the second
trapezoid would look like this this one
looks almost like a rectangle but we
assume that the top isn't completely
flat
and then we go all the way to the nth
one and this should be clear that we're
dealing with a trapezoid
all the way to the nth one it'll look
something
would look something like that so how
would we calculate how would we
calculate this area the area of the
trapezoids
well you just have to remember that the
area of a trapezoid is just the average
of the heights of the two sides times
the base so in this case
let me write it out a little bit so
the area
right over there is going to be the is
going to be the average of the heights
so it's going to be f of x sub naught
plus
f of x sub 1
all of that
all of that over 2 and then we're going
to multiply that times delta x we're
going to multiply that times delta x so
that would be the area just of this one
right over here we took the average of
the two heights and multiplied that
times the base now if we wanted the area
the sum of the areas of all of these
trapezoids and we wanted to write in
general terms we could just write it's
the sum once again we're going to count
we're going to count the trapezoids this
is the first trapezoid this is the
second all the way to the nth trapezoid
so it's i equals 1 to i equals n and the
height of each trapezoid we're going to
use the left boundary the function
evaluated at the left boundary x sub
i minus 1.
the average of the function of value at
the left boundary and the function
evaluated at the right boundary
and we're going to take the average of
that and then multiply that times the
base so the whole reason why i wanted to
do this to show you there's multiple
multiple ways of doing this in fact if
you want to get really general you could
even have different widths but then that
gets a little bit more a little bit more
confusing but really just to show you
that you might see some some of this
fancy notation in your calculus book or
in your precalculus book but all it's
doing is summing up the areas of
trapezoids and rectangles depending on
whether they're using the right
boundaries of the rectangle to define
the height the left boundaries the
midpoint of the left and the right
boundaries or they could even construct
trapezoids